[Musique]
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa cette semaine
on met à l'honneur le cinéma d'animation
japonaise pendant un mois au mois
d'octobre la mairie de saint cyr l'école
a mis à l'honneur le manga par des
expositions un concours de dessins à la
bibliothèque est évidemment beaucoup de
films etc qui ont été diffusées ici et
on clôt cet événement avec la diffusion
en avant première d'un film qui va vous
arriver sur vos écrans à la fin du mois
de décembre qui s'appelle mirail ma
petite soeur d'un monsieur d'un grand
monsieur du cinéma d'animation qui
s'appelle mamoru hosoda il avait réalisé
summer wars mais le plus connu étant à
mai et yuki les enfants lourd un grand
succès à l'époque de sa sortie
je vous invite donc à venir découvrir
mirail ma petite soeur de notre salle
c'est l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui
va avoir une petite soeur comme son nom
l'indiqué puis il est pas très d'accord
avec ça ça m'embête beaucoup et par un
artifice fantastico magique comme
souvent dans le cinéma d'animation
japonais il va se retrouver confronté à
son futur à son destin au destin de sa
petite soeur à mais aussi au passé de
ses parents de ses grands parents il va
être projeté comme ça à travers le temps
et sa vague du coup donné une une sorte
d'ampleur et de réalité à ce qui peut
être la notion de famille et de lien
familial en particulier au japon mais
c'est évidemment un thème universel
je vous invite donc à venir le découvrir
en avant-première à 16 heures ce samedi
1er décembre au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
[Musique]